Outrage is brewing over Mulan's new release
strategy, and it's coming from both movie
theater executives and consumers alike.
Disney's live-action remake of its beloved
1998 animated film Mulan was originally meant
to hit theaters on March 27th, 2020, but in
response to growing concerns over the safety
of movie theaters amid the coronavirus crisis,
it was then delayed until July 24th.
And then to August 21st.
And then removed from the release schedule
altogether.
On August 4th, 2020, Disney made a final,
bold decision when CEO Bob Chapek announced
that Mulan will be released directly to streaming
on Disney+ on September 4th, instead of arriving
in theaters.
Following the announcement that one of the
most anticipated movies of 2020 will bypass
a theatrical release entirely, many have wondered
what the news could mean for the future of
movies as a whole.
For some theater owners and fans, this move
by Disney is a huge problem.
According to a report from Deadline, cinemas
in the UK are furious over Disney's decision
to release Mulan on streaming without even
a limited theatrical run to go alongside it.
Phil Clapp, who serves as the head of the
UK Cinema Association, wrote in a statement,
"The decision not to give cinemas the chance
to play the film (even if day-and-date with
Disney+) is frankly bewildering and something
we've of course gone back to them on."
Though Disney's Bob Chapek did describe Mulan's
release strategy as a "one-off", Clapp and
his fellow theater owners still have some
cause for concern.
As the COVID-19 crisis continues throughout
the world, most places that typically attract
large crowds remain closed.
While some directors, like Tenet mastermind
Christopher Nolan, have remained insistent
that their films be released theatrically,
studios are either pushing back big new releases
or removing dates from their schedules altogether.
Several films, including Wes Anderson's star-studded
feature The French Dispatch, now simply have
no release date at all.
Before it was officially moved to Disney+,
Mulan was facing the same fate.
Many have wondered if the current crisis has
the potential to close US movie theaters for
good.
Films like Tenet will skip a United States
premiere due to the fact that the outbreaks
within the States are much worse than they
are in other locations around the world, so
it's easy to see why UK cinema owners are
frustrated by the choice Disney made with
Mulan.
Still, they may have to adjust to a rapidly
shifting cinematic landscape.
Unfortunately for Disney, the company didn't
just tick off UK cinema owners; the Mouse
House also irritated audiences.
However, fans aren't upset that they can't
see Mulan in theaters and instead have to
watch the flick from the comfort of their
own homes; they're angry at the price of entry.
When word broke about Mulan heading to Disney+,
the news came with a hefty catch: viewers
will have to pay $29.99 to watch the movie...in
addition to their usual subscription costs,
far above the price for a single movie ticket.
However once purchased, subscribers can watch
Mulan as many times as they please, unlike
in theaters which requires a fee for every
showing.
That doesn't mean Disney won't have a hard
time getting viewers to pony up that kind
of money, especially when they already pay
for a Disney+ subscription.
Adding insult to injury for some is the fact
that the live-action Mulan differs too much
from the animated original, with one Twitter
user writing.
"So they're making us pay for it while paying
for the subscription?
For a movie that has no music and no Mushu?
Nah fam, I'm good."
Another added,
"I wouldn't pay $30 for a movie ticket in
the theater.
So I'm not going to pay that to see the new
Mulan, especially when it doesn't have Mushu
or classic songs [from] the animated version."
On the flip side, others have noted that $30
is a small price to pay to watch a blockbuster
movie like Mulan with your entire family,
and that it's important to support a movie
led by an all-Asian cast.
"You know, you just gotta…gotta learn to
let these things go."
Overall, while many are unhappy with the decision
Disney made, only time will tell how things
pan out in terms of both critical response
to the film and the movie's financial gain
from this type of debut.
Those interested can rent Mulan on Disney+
beginning September 4th, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.